it's one of Norway's narrowest and
steepest valleys noorans darlin on the
west coast about 400 kilometers north of
Bergen and it's notorious for frequent
avalanches and landslides spine wash dad
loves to come to the area because he
knows about a very special place here
the mountain lake links to botany
it was the 26th of May 1908 there was an
avalanche coming down from this mountain
and it was so big with rocks that it
makes a barrier down at Valley and after
that the water in this river
was of course rising and this Lake was
born swine [ __ ] runs a diving Center
he regularly goes diving in the lake one
favorite sight is the remains of a
village that vanished during the
landslide 104 years ago remnants of the
sunken village can even be seen from the
shore the old country lane leads us to
the bottom of the lake it used to run
through the entire valley into the
village the water is just a few degrees
above freezing and crystal clear
even the road marker is still here this
was Roush number nine
the first signs of the village are its
stone walls up to 30 people once tended
livestock here now all is still and
quiet at the floor of the lake
underwater this breach made of
fieldstone serves little purpose but
once it fled over the lien a small
Mountain Brook it was blocked in the
landslide and became this lake
first fine wash dirt every dive is a
journey into the past
yeah I thought I I look there's a goat
but it may be a sheep around here or
some cows and I see people and I imagine
this and I see the trees and I see the
gates and the fences it was very good I
feel like being here
I let the skirt it's fantastic that I
think imagine I think about swimming
between the trees fantastic when you see
the branches and everything that's good
these boulders some of them more than 5
meters wide are what destroyed the
village it seems like a miracle that no
villagers came to harm
the Norwegian government has also taken
an interest in a submerged village and
the government says we have to protect
it and maybe there is a restriction for
next year I don't know this year it
hasn't been any far so far but maybe
only areas in the woods that only
smokers not divers
that means today may be one of the last
journeys into an underwater world which
few people have ever seen